how do you even open it oh I've held in
the bunch mainly waiting for other
people to finish what they're doing I
feel like I should be somewhat
accustomed to knowing what purse is more
expensive based on the hours that I
spend watching my family shop for versus
[Music]
brands are covered so my initial way of
determining what's more expensive is off
the table my first thought is that both
of these are really ugly
somebody told me look out for the
zippers so maybe this is the key you can
tell how expensive something is by the
lining the material seems kind of like
synthetic I'm just going to massage the
interior of both of these inside kind of
looks like a really cheap suit this just
looks like something that like happened
in the Cadillac in the eighties I think
this is the more expensive one now based
on the the lining this is more expensive
in this one I would guess that this one
is more expensive and going with this
one
this purse is atrocious this one's got
this nice cow feature on it there's a
cow and a Dalmatian had a baby or is it
down nation I don't know
this is karela de villes purse my eye is
drawn to the leopard print and it feels
like a suitcase which is not okay with
me it's mostly at t.j.maxx
this is like I'm going out but I'm I
don't need that much it's just gonna be
me tonight this is the cub probably the
kind of purse that I would wear it's
like something my mom maybe had in like
1987 this feels like more of a regular
everyday bag but the leather feels a lot
nicer it feels and smells like real
leather this feels so gross and fake
that if this is more expensive I'm gonna
revolt
I'm gonna go this one more expensive and
I think this cost more I think this is
the more expensive one this is more
expensive right this is more expensive
what the [ __ ] this is one of the worst
persons I've ever seen
[Music]
this is not a purse this is actually a
purse what do you put it how do you open
it oh you just push it oh it's a button
just push it so I know that this is a
clutch for dragon lady this looks like
something that Indiana Jones would
recover from a cage really uncomfortable
so probably more expensive if this
seemed to have a strap would it be a
clutch or would it just be a paperweight
and there's this thing it's very
rectangular quite like this purse this
would make a good couch yeah in the
1980s a special edition boombox might
come into this carrying case I'm gonna
go with a the smaller the more expensive
I'm gonna say the clutch is more
expensive I'm gonna go this one they're
both absurd shapes that I wouldn't want
to carry around ever and I think this
one cost more I'm gonna go on a limb and
say this is the expensive one
yes yes surely nobody's buying this to
actually use it so it's just like a
beanie baby at this point
[Music]
I'm gonna work really hard and then
spend it on an empty thing it's
literally an empty thing it's an empty
purchase you could go anywhere in the
world for what one of these purses cost
if I was a woman I know I would be
buying the most expensive purses for
sure if you have the money and if it
makes you feel good then awesome just
make sure you have good taste because
some of that expensive looks like
purses are dumb why don't people learn
to make their own purses how hard could
agree you don't have to look nice either